i'm
talking about basic things about you
know tensors low rank
tensor rank border rank
and approximation so let's get going
okay so the setting is the following we
have a couple of vector spaces v one up
to v p
um vector spaces over a field k
and the dimension of v i is n i
so we'll be looking at
the tensor product of these vector
spaces v1 turns our v2 all the way up to
vp
which is a large vector space of
dimension n1 times n2 all the way up to
np
and now this is sort of a mathematical
way of looking at a tensors but but if
you like there's also a
say a coordinate based way of looking at
tensors which which is that the elements
of this vector space are just b
way
arrays of numbers with sides and 1 times
n2 all the way up to np
now
by definition of the tensor product
every tensor is a is a sum of uh pure
tensors
tensors of the form v
i one tends for v i two up to v i p
and um
so every every tensor is of that form
for some number k up here
now that expression is not minimal and
not not unique which is
to a large extent why we are here today
and the minimal k in any such expression
is called the rank of that tensor u
now the tensor rank is a is a somewhat
ill-behaved notion
uh for instance
it
it may depend on the field so if you if
you enlarge your field if your tens are
all these vector spaces with the field
extension of k then the tensor rank can
go down
and also being of of
of rank at most some number is not a
closed condition in fact for both of
these there's a nice example that uh
legend lim and
vin de silva described which is that if
you look at
you in
okay when r2 turns or r2
turns on r2
then on this space there is a
nice invariant called the
hyperdeterminant
kaylee's hyper determinant
and
and there are three cases
namely
delta of u is negative then
then the rank
of uh of the real numbers of u
is equal to three
while the rank of the of the complex
numbers of u is equal to two
and uh
delta u is positive
in which case the rank
i guess is the same
only two
and then
it might also be zero and then it's many
things or several different things can
happen but but one of the things and
that can happen and that's in fact the
general
generic case
is that the rank over the real numbers
of u is the rank of the complex numbers
of u is equal to three
so you see
over here that the uh that the rank can
drop when you extend the field and here
you see that it can happen that that
tensors that have rank three
namely with delta
equal to zero can be arbitrarily well
approximated by things that have rank
two namely with positive delta
that's the non-closeness of that
condition
okay so the border rank takes takes away
those two problems
namely it's the minimal case such that
you lies in this a risky closure of the
set of all tensors of rank at most k
and when i say that takes care of those
two problems i'm assuming that k is an
infinite field if k is finite then
sort of the border rank is the same as
the rank if you define it this way and
it's it's an
interesting
note
okay
now
the reason why it would be interesting
to to approximate arbitrary tensors by
low rank tensors is that they form a
lower dimensional variety so the tensors
of border rank at most k they form a
variety of dimension at most k times so
case for the number of terms in here
the dimension that you need to the
number of uh
say coordinates that you need to
describe such a tensor and that's the
sum
for i is one up to p of ni minus one
plus one
basically because each of these is from
an ni dimensional vector space where i
guess i should say nj because
i mean something else here
but you can move scalars in front so
that accounts for the minus one here and
the one over here
now in particular if k is very small
then this is of course a number that's
much smaller than n1 times n2 all the
way up to mp so so you might want to try
to
check whether tensors have have low rank
or try to approximate tensors by things
of low rank
okay so what do we mean by approximating
okay
so in the rest of the talk i'll be
talking exclusively about real numbers
and complex numbers
so for now k is the real numbers and
each vi is equipped with a
positive definite inner product
and we give v the inner product that is
determined by this expression if you
take the inner product of two
pure tensors to rank one tensors
then that is the product for i is one up
to p of the inner products of these guys
it's easy to see that there's a unique
such in our product and
and that's in some sense the the most
natural type of inner product to equip
this this vector space v with
okay so now you might wonder given a
tensor in v
and given a natural number k
uh
how do we find a x in v of rank at most
k that minimizes the the square distance
to uh
to the given tensor um
so many people also from applications
people like living the liv live and the
lot tower have have studied this problem
and sort of gave a given
local or heuristic optimization
algorithms for trying to to find that
minimum
um
does this minimum depend on your choice
of inner product
i mean this in a product that i've
exposed i changed in your product of
course it will check than this minimum
yeah the best approximation will
change yeah
let me
i mean certainly that's going to be true
when when i take an arbitrary now
product on v
if it comes from inner products on the
vi all right
let's take a reasonable inner product so
when it comes from
inner products on the bis that was
really the question i meant to ask okay
i see
um
i'm not sure let me get back to that
maybe okay the value of d would be
different but yeah certainly the value
will might be different but
the x the the the optimizing the
minimizer yeah no that's a good point um
let me
think about it and then should get back
to it
um
okay so um
so i was saying so so people study this
problem and have various type of
heuristic algorithms and one of the
problems with such algorithms is that
that they might get stuck in local
minima
and that sort of motivated us to to
study the following problem namely given
a tensor try to count the number of
critical points of of this function on
the
the smooth part of this set whatever
that means okay so it's the set of
tensors of rank at most
and now i'll make my life completely
easy
and even then there are interesting
things to say namely i'll i'll study
entirely i mean for most of this talk
i'll say only things about k is equal to
one and sorry to ask the same question
again but yeah at least for this related
problem can you prove that that's
independent of the reasonable choice of
inner product the number of critical
points yes yes so this number of
critical points is going to be
independent
of the choice of the of the reasonable
inner product that's right
yeah maybe for your question i mean
i think it does depend
i'm not boring one but foreign you can
see it already for matrices right or
even for two factors because the two
factors the
minimum rank decomposition we're just um
that's right yeah
singular vectors and they are orthogonal
but with respect to the inner products
but they will not give us a very good
point
why do you want to count i thought you
would want to find this critical point
that is right
that's what we really like so well there
are two answers to that one is so i'll
be saying mostly things about the real
numbers and and this at least this count
gives some sort of measure of
complexity for these heuristic
algorithms that might run into local
minima
another thing is if you count them of
the complex numbers and you generate
i mean the most naive algorithm for
trying to find this minimizer is
enumerating all critical points and if
you can count them then you know when
you are done i'm not claiming that this
is a efficient algorithm for finding
them
okay so uh so here's indeed matrices so
thanks
um
okay so
we'll we'll study the set x which is the
set of uh
rank at most in fact rank one tensors
it's a it's a smooth manifold of uh
also called pure tensors and what we
want is given a tensor count the
critical points of du on that smooth
manifold
x now there's an important observation
which is that if you fix those inner
products then
then this this question here is
doesn't change when you uh when you act
with an element of the product of the
orthogonal groups
right simply because this product of the
orthogonal groups preserves both x
and
the the the inner product that we're
studying
so so here's the very basic case that
was already alluded to namely if p is
equal to two then
two weight sensors are just matrices and
then there there is that
if you want
a special case of the eckhart young
theorem which tells you what what the
answer is to this question namely
um
given any sensor
u
there are elements g1 and g2 in the
orthogonal groups of v1 and v2 such that
if you apply their tensor product or
to to to you then you're going to get
a tensor in normal form which means it's
a sum
for i is one up to the minimum of n1 and
n2 which is n1
of c i times e i tends or f i where
where these are orthonormal and these
are orthonormal
and
and moreover you can arrange it such
that all these number c i's are
decreasing and that are
non-negative and then they're known as
the singular values and well if you have
a tensor of this form it's a very simple
computation
to find out what the
um
what what the critical points of the
distance function are namely they are
just for each i from one not two and one
they are just ci times e i tend to fi
so since this problem is invariant under
this group you get the critical points
for the original u by applying g
one inverse g two inverse to that
and indeed uh if you change your
uh inner product this decomposition
might
uh so actually eugene is uh you know
eckhart young theorem is you know has
been extended by miersky it's a young
minsky's theorem and what he shows is
that
uh regardless of your choice as long as
it's invariant under this action
it's always given by the singular value
decomposition x doesn't depend on the
choice not in fact for matrices it
doesn't
that you know that's approximation x
you mean if you if you choose any inner
product on v that is invariant under
this product of groups then it's like it
doesn't even i see it come from
i see you know that's very under this
action
um
can you say that again yeah so if you
look at the previous slide uh yeah
sure yeah so this norm here right of
course in in this case it comes from an
inner product but any norm that is
invariant under that uh four ov one
you fix everything that you need to
prove that but it's a good point
why is it
greatly more than zero uh
um so they're not eigenvalues right
there or there are eigenvalues of a
positive definite matrix that you get
sometimes it's transposed
no no you're not finding eigenvalues of
a you're finding eigenvalues of a
transpose exactly
so you can absorb the phases into the e
i be like worthy
that's right if if
yeah
i mean if if if one is negative then you
multiply the e i with minus
okay so that's rank one approximation
for matrices
um
now for
ordinary tensors here's a fact that that
is that this number of critical points
is typically not not constant
it's going to jump across some
hypersurface
of which i have unfortunately very
little to say
um so so the question of the real
numbers that i post doesn't make sense
there's no single number that to to
compute so what we do is we're going to
compute an average so
we we are going to draw you from a
probability distribution and then
compute the average number of critical
points that you get in this way
okay so so here's the theorem
namely if you draw u uniformly from the
unit sphere in in v with respect to this
inner product that i defined
um
then
then the expected number of critical
points of of this distance function to
you is this expression
okay so what's important about this
expression well there are things that
you recognize from i don't know volumes
of spheres and other things and gaussian
distributions there's a two pi to some
power there's some gammas and there's a
uh
a bolt a math bolt-faced e with uh
an absolute value of a determinant so
what's that well
this c itself is going to be a random
matrix of which i'll describe the
structure in detail on the on the next
slide and this e is the expected value
of the absolute value of the determinant
of that random matrix
there are some
notations so n is the sum of the
ni's and p is the number of vectors that
we had before
and c so another thing that's important
about this expression is that c is not a
very large matrix but but in fact a
rather small matrix it's
so it's roughly the sum of the ni's
times the sum of the ni's except that
you subtract b from each
so can you give us an idea of let's say
we fix fix p equal to three even
and
let the ends grow uh what does this
function grow like
um i don't understand maybe it's too
early in the morning for me to
do this kind of thing in my head yeah so
i'll give some numbers later on
um actually yeah
not for not so much for fixed p and uh
running and well let me let me give some
numbers later we we haven't actually
figure out exactly
uh the asymptotics of this uh of this
expected value of the determinant does
it does it is it increasing or
decreasing even it looks like it's
if you fix p i'll i'll get back to that
too
there will be numbers okay
actually what's interesting is
i think
might be the case where you where you
fix the ends and let the p run because
then then this is a problem that looks
similar to what people in random matrix
theory do so then this this
matrix c looks very similar to
say standard gaussian and samplers that
people said so then it might be possible
to say any something about the
asymptotics but we have not yet done
okay so so
so what's important about this formula
is um is that so suppose that you would
want to compute this expected number of
critical points in a straightforward
manner well then you would have to
sample u from a very high dimensional
space and one times n2 etc
and for each of those use you would have
to compute the the number of real
critical points of the u
whereas if you want to compute it using
this formula you only need to
uh
to sample sort of relatively small
matrices c and compute their their
determinant which is which is much
faster than
the other
original thing
okay so here's the structure of c it's
it's a symmetric matrix first of all
and it has blocks that are size ni minus
one times nj minus one
and so they are cijs and on the
diagonals we have scalar multiples of
the identity matrices so with a fixed
scalar w zero
and in this uh so this is a random
matrix so the entries are random numbers
and in fact they're all independent and
um
and uh
distributed a lot according to the
standard calcium distribution okay
so let's do a sanity check that this is
what's uh what it should be according to
to the echo jung theorem for for
matrices and in fact yesterday on the
plane it was even later
i didn't do the general matrix case that
that
two by two matrix case then this matrix
c looks like this it's w zero w one two
w one two w zero and the absolute value
of the determinant is just this
expression and what's important about
this expression and also in the case in
the general matrix cases that it's easy
to see when it is positive or negative
it factorizes
um so that this this expectation that
you have here which is some you know
some integral it's easy to split into
parts where where the where the sign of
the determinant is
definite
and
so you can compute this expected value
it's 4 over pi and then plugging that in
the formula of the previous slide you
get 2 pi to the power
1 divided by 2 squared times 1 this is
for the gammas times four over pi which
is two okay
okay
now
i'd like to compare this to the to the
corresponding count of the complex
numbers and for that i'd like to say
something more general about
what we call the euclidean distance
degree so the the more general stuff is
in blue today or sort of
dark cia cyan cyan
according to my
pipe
so the more general problem is the
following you're given a real algebraic
variety x in a euclidean space so we're
real vector space with a positive
definite inner product
and you're given a point and you'd like
to say sufficiently general and you'd
like to count the critical points of the
of the this the squared distance
function on the manifold of of smooth
points
so that's equivalent to to counting the
points x here where uh u minus x is
perpendicular to the uh to the tension
space to x at x
and this means that locally uh
the distance to x
is either a minimum or a maximum or at
least it's a critical one
okay so
now this is a difficult problem one of
the reasons being that it's not not well
defined because that number of critical
points is not fixed so what we do is we
we is
myself and emil robertson ottaviani
branstormfels and reika thomas is to
complexify this inner product to a
symmetric bilinear form on the on the
corresponding complex vector space so
it's important here that this is a
symmetric bilinear form and not a not a
hermitian form
so that means that that in particular
this expression
can be can be zero even if the vector in
in between is not zero
okay so then uh
then if you do the corresponding count
over the of the complex numbers you find
that if your v is sufficiently general
then the number of smooth points in the
complexification of x
uh for which u minus x is perpendicular
to this tension space is some constant
and we call it the ed degree of of this
variety x or of of its complexification
and
what we've been concerned with on the
previous slide is the average ed degree
which is defined with respect to a
probability measure on the on the
euclidean space v so it's the it's the
expected number of critical points for a
random u in v
so this is a complex count and this is a
it's a real count
okay so let me tell you what the ed
degree is for rank one tensors
um
yeah so
now we complexify that inner product
that we had before to a symmetric
bilinear form on this tensor product
and xc is now the the
smooth complex manifold of of complex
pure tensors
and then the theorem due to schmol fr
friedland and
giorgio ottaviane
is that
the dd degree of x
is the coefficient of this monomial as 1
to the n 1 minus 1 times sp to the np
minus 1
in
this polynomial
so this doesn't quite look like a
polynomial but it is
so
here s i hat is just the sum of all s 1
up to s p except as i
and
it's clear that this
numerator is divisible by this
denominator so
this is a polynomial and in that
polynomial you take this the coefficient
of this thing in particular that that's
a positive number and um
that's what it is okay so let's do the
same kind of sanity check that we did
did for the average case
uh here we should get two again for the
same reason as in the previous case
i mean we should get and the minimum of
n1 and n2 i should take
okay so p is two and one is at most then
two and then this expression says well
you take the coefficient of this in this
expression
and then
there's there are some heads missing
here i'm sorry
uh this oh no no no i repeat it i
replace the things with the heads
already by the so as one hat would be s2
and s2 had would be as one
so that's this expression here
and now if you expand that you get the
sum of these monomials and the sum of
these monomials and now if you want to
get the coefficient of s1 to the n1
minus 1 times s2 to the m
2 minus 1 you see it appears as the
product of this guy and this guy and
also as the product of the previous guy
and the previous guy here etc
and you can keep on going until the
minimum of s1
of n1 and n2
which is n1 because that's what we
issued
okay
okay so now
in the rest of this talk i'd like to
give some some of the main ideas that go
into proving this statement and the the
previous statement and one of the
um
one of the common denominators or the
maybe the common denominator is the
is something that i'll discuss on the
next slide okay
um
so before before going into that let me
describe some numbers
you get some numbers so here
um
here are some tensor formats here are ed
degrees according to the formula
due to friedland and ottaviani and here
are say our numbers
um
so for instance if you if you take two
to some high power
then
then that matrix c that i described
looks like this
so it's just uh
w0 w0
so it's just a
roughly speaking a standard uh
random symmetric matrix matrix with
gaussian entries except that the
diagonal is constant and that it is
scaled such that it is n 0 1 and not n
0 2 or square root 2 or 1 over square
root 2 or 1 over 2 whichever is the one
that that usually people in random
matrices look at
nevertheless it should be possible to to
compare these say
these numbers as p growth to to the
asymptotic behavior of the determinant
of a of a standard uh
a matrix c in the standard gaussian
ensem
so so here you get p factorial and here
you get something that grows slightly
slower so here it gets multiplied with
roughly three roughly three a bit more
than three bit more than three roughly
four
but but we don't know
the exact asymptotics for this either
yet now there's another intriguing
phenomenon
which is a theorem over the complex
numbers and so far just experimental
over the real numbers which is that
that if you
if you fix the last
um
say the largest
uh ni let's call that let's take the
last one to bnp and if you take that
such that mp minus one is at least the
sum for i is 1 up to p minus 1
of n i minus 1.
then
the ed degree of the complex numbers
doesn't change anymore
so you see that happening here three
minus one is two is at least
one plus one
so from that point on if you increase
the last one uh this count doesn't
doesn't change anymore
um
so
i'd like to stress here that this is
you would expect such behavior when uh
when np is say at least the the product
of the and one of to np or then it's
very easy to prove but but that that
stabilization already happens at this
point and that's a theorem
uh which follows from the formula in the
complex case but there's no known
geometric proof for that theorem
so there's no sort of bijective proof
that shows that these numbers are the
same and if you do the corresponding
computation over the real numbers then
you see something
even maybe funnier which is that this
number seems to slightly decrease rather
than stabilize
we've run these computations quite often
so
i'm fairly certain that this is not just
numerical errors and that it that it
should really uh stabilize but that it's
really slightly decreasing listen what's
the difference between the red and the
black
so the only thing is that the red
illustrates this stabilization behavior
that i'm just describing otherwise
there's no difference so it happens over
here and also over here
okay so that
that common denominator in the two
proofs is
is what we call
in general so in blue the uh ed
correspondence
so we're back in the general setting
where we have some real algebraic
variety x and we
we look at
e of curly e of x which is the set of
all pairs x comma u where x is critical
for d u so in other words u minus x is
perpendicular to the tangent space
and well that might not be a closed set
so we take the closure of that
and this is something that you can do
both over the real numbers and of the
complex numbers and in fact
we'll
both of these so so i'll use the same
notation in both cases
now there's a there are two observations
first of all
if you take the projection to v
then then the fibers of that projection
are exactly the things that of which we
want to counter cardinality because if
you're given a u you want to know how
many x's there are for which this is
critical
on the other hand if you take the
projection to x then this is an affine
vector bundle of
uh of rank the code dimension of x
and
y
it is it's fairly obvious from a picture
because if you
say
for later purposes let me draw my x like
this so if i take so this is some
some cone like this so if i take an x
here then
then what are they used for which it is
critical well they're just the ones on
the normal
uh to the variety x uh through the point
x
so this is a
straight angle here
yeah so that's an affine
vector space
or whose dimension is
has complementary dimension to the
dimension of x itself
okay so that's
that's the ed correspondence and now
sometimes if if x is like in this
picture a cone which means that it is
closed under scalar multiplication
then then it's more convenient to work
with the projective variety so p x is
the projective variety in pv
and you can take the image of p
e x in px times v
and then what happens is that
if you take this point x over here or
you take it's a scalar multiple of it
then
then these two um fine vector spaces
are the same except that they are have
been translated a little bit
so that means that if
if you take the
fiber over a projective point
x with
with square brackets you're going to get
an entire
uh
plane like this in this picture so
you're going to get something which is
which is spanned by the orthogonal
complement of the tension space plus x
and this is a direct sum provided that x
is not perpendicular to itself
yeah if x were perpendicular to itself
then then this would already be
contained in this
now if you're working of the real
numbers there are no points that are
perpendicular to themselves so then it's
always really this but if you work of
the complex numbers you have to worry
about
about these points that are
that are perpendicular to themselves
okay so the conclusion of this is that
the projective ed correspondence is also
a is now not an affine vector bundle but
really a vector bundle over
over the real of the the regular locus
of this projected variety
um of rank the codin dimension of x plus
one because of this uh business over
here
at least if you stay away from the set
of points that are perpendicular to
themselves
now
to give an idea about the proof of the
friedland octaviani formula
uh
we need some notions some some notions
having to do with vector bundles
yeah we we have a vector bundle e x
or p e x and um
now if you're given a
a data point v
then you can think of that as a section
of the of the trivial bundle namely uh
the
the section that assigns to every point
in x that data point u
yeah so this gives a say the constant
function from p x to v that assigns to
any point v
and you can take the quotient of this
trivial bundle by the by the vector
bundle that we have over here and
roughly speaking the idi degree counts
the zeros of this sections of this
section but again you have to be careful
at q and you have to be careful
so
e x is the incidence curves from it yes
that's right
and then okay now
next slide
so
so maybe you'd maybe you don't like this
notation but that so
it's your talk you could use the
notation i just want to understand it
and i got it now okay okay great
i wanted to avoid o's and uh
okay
now
whenever you have a vector bundle whose
rank is equal to the dimension of the of
the projected variety
which which this vector bundle has
because because this one had
uh
rank
i i was confused by your abusive use of
e for two different things on the slide
and that's some that's right yeah maybe
this e is the quotient over here
so if you have a general vector bundle
whose rank is equal to the dimension of
your of your uh projected variety and
there are technical conditions such that
such as that your vector bundle should
uh
should locally generate
should be
what's the word
should be globally generated
um
then then the the zeros of such a
general section are counted by the
degree of the top churn class of that
vector bundle and this is something that
lives in the ciao ring of or the
co-homology ring if you want of the
projected variety px
so roughly speaking if you if you
understand the ciao ring and if you
understand the behavior at singular
points and and that q then then you can
maybe say something about the ed degree
now back to our setting x is a pure is
the variety of pure tensors so px
is just uh the segre embedding of a
product of projective spaces so that's a
smooth variety of which we know the ciao
ring very well it's just
the
the polynomial ring over the integers in
s1 up to sp modulo
the ideal generated by these expressions
of three
okay so let's let's quickly give give
give an id of the proof of that
formula so here's the formula again
um obviously we're going to need the
tangent space so what's the tangent
space to the variety x at a pure tensor
of this well you get it by by just
varying
by the life needs rule basically you're
you're going to get it by
varying for each day running from one to
p the the j vector so it's the sum over
j is one up to p of such a product where
only the j vector is a it's an entire
vector source
this is not a direct sum because
because all of them intersect in in the
original
vector v1 tensor up to vp
okay so now
here we go
remember we wanted to count for a
general point u
the number of uh
x such that this lies in the projective
ed correspondent now this is equivalent
to saying that there exists a c such
that u minus c times x is perpendicular
to the tangent space
which is
this expression
and
now if we assume that x is good so that
it's not perpendicular to it itself then
you can write
this space
as a direct sum of x itself and
the corresponding space but but with v i
capital v i replaced by the orthogonal
complement of of v i
so let's do that and let's assume this
so then this is the same thing as there
exists a c such as for all
i that's the same and then two things
must hold namely u minus c x must be
perpendicular to x and you must be
perpendicular to this because x itself
is already perpendicular to this
now
this c doesn't appear here anymore it
appears only here and by
choosing that c we can always achieve
this because again x is not
perpendicular to itself so this is the
same thing as saying that u is
perpendicular to this
uh tensor product
so now if you take
if you define another vector bundle
which is somewhat close to the project
projective
to the quotient of the trivial bundle by
the projective ed correspondence but not
quite it because this is something that
defined also at uh
at points that are that are
perpendicular to themselves so if you if
you take e i to be the bundle of
on px
where the fiber over x
is this vector space so it's roughly
this vector space but you take the dual
then you can think of a tensor as giving
a section
on each of these
e i's and hence
a section of the of the direct sum of
these e i's namely that you gives by
taking inner products that that you is
going to give a
a linear form on this space over here so
hence an element of this dual space
and the uh the zeros of that section are
exactly the axis that we're trying to
count and now i'm sweeping under the rug
this business about q
okay
now the turn class of this vector bundle
is exactly this coefficient over here so
this is a direct sum of
of vector bundles that translates into a
to a product of the corresponding term
classes
okay so that's that formula now the
other formula
also uses the
ed correspondence or the incidence
correspondence
um
so how does it work well there's a very
sort of
naive double counting argument oh this
is not what i wanted
so imagine that that ed correspondents
look somewhat like this
then
so so what you're trying to compute is
some weighted average of one which is
the
the number of
the size of the fiber here and three
which is the size of the fiber here and
one which is the size of the fiber here
then what you can do if your probability
distribution here is given by a density
function or by a volume form then you
can pull back that volume form
to this ed correspondence and compute
the integral here rather than down here
and now uh so i call this double
counting because given you know given
u-width is difficult to compute the axis
but given x it's easy to compute to use
so so we're trying to we're going to
compute the integral over that ed
correspondent and this is the formula
that you get so the integral over v
of these fiber sizes times the density d
u this is just
the back measure
is the integral oh there's one more step
here which is that
if you also have a nice parameterization
from r to the right dimension
to uh to the um
to the ed correspondence then
then you can pull back this this
computation of the integral on this to
to the
to r to that dimension r one in this
case
so what you're going to get is that this
expression that you want to compute is
the integral over r to the dimension of
the jacobian of
pi composed with
phi
sorry
this should be a phi
over here
at t times the density evaluated at pi 2
phi of t dt
now if your x happens to be a rational
variety then you can take
then you can not only parameterize x by
rationally but also the
the ed correspondent or even the
projective ed correspondents if that if
that's more convenient
okay so
so here's how that works
some details
namely you fix some
norm 1 vectors e i and v i
and you let
w be
the orthogonal complement of the direct
sum now it's a direct sum of e1 tends or
tends or ei by throwing complement up to
ap and this is the fiber over this
projective point in this projective ed
correspondence
um
and the the bi-rational map from
by means of which i parameterize this
this projective variety is just the map
that that takes a tuple of vectors v1 up
to vp in the orthogonal complements here
and takes their tensor product
after adding them to
to e
i and that's a bi-rational map from from
this vector space to this projective
right
and
now
if you would like to know the fiber over
over this point rather than this
original point then you just take the
fiber w and you hit it with a product of
i mean a tuple of orthogonal maps where
uh
where the orthogonal mapped is such that
it maps e i into the corresponding thing
here namely e i plus v i
strictly speaking i mean the projective
point e i into this projective part
now there are many such maps
but but one such choice is this
expression over here so
this is just a projection to the
orthogonal complement of e i and v i
so in other words g i is going to be
the identity on that orthogonal
complement and this is the the the
matrix of determinant one that maps e i
to
uh
to to e i plus v i
and that is orthogonal
and so now what's important about this
expression is that the choice of course
depends on you on the numbers v1 up to
vp so now we get a parameterization of
this projective ed correspondence that
takes v1 up to vp into
um
this should have been a
sorry i mixed up letters this should
have been a phi and this should have
been a psi of v1 up to vp and then g
applied to w and there's an implicit in
dependence on v1 up to vp here because g
itself depends on v1 up to vp
so you you do this computation that i
that i wrote down
for this particular case and you note
that
that this jacobian matrix has a very
large block which is just the identity
matrix
and that accounts for the the for the
reduction in dimension that i stressed
at the beginning
so
this determinant over here is a you need
to compute only a determinant of a very
small
sub matrix of that
jacob okay so that's that's a rough
sketch of how to prove that
formula
now i'll be rather brief about this
you can also do things over the for
symmetric
tensors there you equip the space of
the p symmetric power of r n with the
positive n product that satisfies this
rule
sometimes it's called the bombieri inner
product
now you want to approximate a tensor u
by an element of x which is the set of
all plus or minus v to the power p where
v runs through this set
this plus or minus is necessarily only
when p is an even number
and
again if you draw you from the univer
form distribution on the unit sphere
then you can compute the expected number
of critical points and now in fact the
dimension
goes down all the way up to n that's
right all the way all the way down up to
n so
p plays a role in this formula only
through its occurrence in the arguments
of this integral
so it's an integral there are some
familiar gammas and
there are no pies here but they are sort
of hidden
and there's an integral over
sort of eigenvalues of something lambda
2 up to lambda n which should be ordered
and then there's this product
etc etc and and when when p is equal to
two
you can compute this and it is what it
should be namely n
but it turns out that in fact
also
what's my point
uh that that for fixed certain fixed
values of n
there are also nice nice formulas so for
for n is equal to two so this is
rational normal curves if you want you
get average ed degrees that are 1 2
square root 7 square root 10 square root
13 et cetera
and for for n equal to 3 you're going to
get numbers one three and then some some
more complicated expressions and we
don't really know we haven't been able
to extrapolate these formulas into the
rest of this thing but it's conceivable
that there's a that there's a closed
form
formula in general
now on the left are the ed degrees over
the complex numbers and they had been
known already before
friedland and ottaviano's work
is it obvious that these are algebraic
numbers true
that's a good question i don't know
it's certainly not obvious it's true
here i believe it's true always i
i so
i discussed this with people doing
integrals and but they they didn't they
didn't care about algebraic numbers so
they did
they couldn't give me any hint
yeah
that would be a first step towards
finding a closed form solution
proving that they're algebraic
um okay
so uh there's a theorem due to justin
cartwright and brent stormfields which
gives the ed degree in this case
okay so here's a
here are some last further remarks
i didn't
make this explicit but i mentioned that
for matrices these
there's a singular value decomposition
and um legend has work on
sort of singular values for arbitrary
tensors and they are exactly these so
these critical
uh
rank one approximations to the center
and in the symmetric case they are these
things that are counted by this formula
are the eigenvectors of
a symmetric tensor
now if you change inner products on v
then
if you do it sort of continuously then
your average count is going to
change continuously but your your
complex count is going to jump
and we know
we know sort of the generic uh formula
so there's a very nice
theorem
in our paper that i'll mention later
that deals with with the tauric
varieties of rhetoric varieties and sort
of general
in our products
there's there's there's a formula a
combinatorial formula for the ed degree
now the closed form expression we
discussed already a little bit i think
it should be possible using these
methods to also study the number of
local minima rather than just all
critical points
here's a very annoying thing i do not
even know the
uh the hypersurface in the two by two by
two case where this uh where this cut
where this thing jumps
this fiber i know that all three
possible values two four and six occur
but i i don't know
what the hypersurface is
uh it might be nice in general to know
what are all the typical values so the
ones that are attained in open sets
right now hypersurface has to come from
trio representation of the orthogonal
group that's right yes yes so so it's
very so important so
i guess we don't know the degree right
in this case
no it's maybe for certain generic
choices
so i mentioned the stabilization issue i
think this is a very nice geometric
question uh give a proof of that
now this is a sort of
speculative i don't have anything
sensible to say about how the knowledge
of these ed degrees can be used in in
finding
best approximations and but then the
last thing is rank two i think in
general
for general rank things will be
extremely difficult but rank two should
be something where maybe both of the two
computations should be doable
okay here are some references
and thank you
questions for ya yes
so
you can compute the best one
approximation also by
maximizing or the function associated to
the tensor on the university
or the product
so
these critical points for the function
are related to
the critical points you compute here i
think they're exactly the same
sorry maybe maybe i don't i think
they're exactly the same thing
and actually about the algorithms what
so one thing that people do in the case
of
in the case of ordinary tensors is that
you fix you start with some
guess and then you fix all but
say p minus one of the vectors and then
you optimize in the in the remaining
vector and you repeat this for you know
all possible
choices and
but it's not clear that that should
always
i think it's known that that does not
always converge to the global optimum
ask a wild question that's very wild
what about non-negative rank
um
some of the techniques some of the
techniques might work the
parameterization at least give you a
setting to which integrals to do
yeah
yeah if you i
i mean we use a parameterization so so i
think i mean writing
down something should be easy but
then actually finding a nice expression
for those integrals should be there
when you said rank do you mean
borderline was it really right rank two
um
yeah that's a good that's a good point
uh i guess i mean really rank two over
the real number
you're wondering about this
business right so of the real numbers i
would i i think i would like to start
really with a
parameterization
uh and and and do rank but over the
complex numbers it doesn't really matter
because i mean the the rank two things
are dense in the border rank two things
so
any other questions for speaker if not
let's thank jan again for a while